hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar taking control of the unknown
nanoparticle
containment I am Alexis Krause of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by lab không có to learn more about
our sponsor please visit
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credit please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker David was Setia product product
manager at Loch Kongo corporation for
the complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen David you may now
begin your presentation
great well thanks for joining us today
I'm going to talk a little bit about a
couple of different things in nano
containment we'll talk a little bit
about nano just a background and then
we'll get into some containment options
and and how to really assess how those
those containment options are working
and tested so without further ado let me
dive just dive right in
so nanotechnology can be defined really
by looking at the size of the items that
you might be researching or maybe a
process that you're carrying out is
producing typically we think about nano
materials is being in the 100 nanometer
range and and these are items or these
are material that are a lot smaller than
traditional chemical powders so if you
were to look at the pharmaceutical
powder or chemical powder are typically
going to be significantly larger than
nanomaterials so if we look at some
uniqueness of nanomaterials and why
there is a concern with handling these
types of materials it's largely based on
the amount of surface area that nano
material is going to have so if you
expose more and more surface area by
reducing the size of a particle you're
basically creating a interaction with
you know potential interaction with your
body or anything that you become and
come into contact with that's a nano
material it has more biologically
available space so a good way to think
about this in different concepts is
imagine you have a cube that's the size
of the room you're sitting in right now
so maybe it's 10 by 20 feet I guess
would be a rectangle but anyway a large
volume if you were to divide that up
into several smaller pieces you're now
exposing the surface area that was
formerly hidden within that larger box
shape and if that surface is
biologically relevant to your body
perhaps in a negative manner that can
cause an unwanted impact so imagine that
in your lungs etc unique thing about
nanomaterials is sometimes they behave
very differently than their larger
structures
so here's classic example of
old so gold the lead brick form or the
solid brick form is in a big bar
structure and it has a gold appearance
but if you actually nano materialize
that goal it's going to look more like
the liquid on the right which is the red
solution so they can behave differently
in items can behave differently when
they're produced in nano material sizes
nano materials are also generated from a
couple of different sources so here
you'll see a couple of examples of
natural versus engineered nanomaterials
so scary thought but nano materials are
in environments that we pass her every
day so or in exhaust they are produced
by wildfires they're produced by even
some some organisms produce things are
in the name of material size but even
more so to focus should be placed on
engineered materials because not only
are these you know nanomaterials and
size but we're forcing kind of
properties and and unique features about
nanomaterials that may not just be
biologically or naturally relevant and
could have more increase increased
impact on health to those who might be
exposed to these materials
so kind of talked about some of their
unique features and their different
behaviors another important thing to
consider is that nanomaterials research
is really still in a very budding state
of its its
overall development so you think about
pharmaceutical powders well we've known
a lot about different types of drug
powders for a long time but
nanomaterials are still very new people
are doing lots of interesting
experiments and and and creating new
materials that have not existed prior to
you know current research going on so
that's just a important thing to
consider when you're realizing you may
be working with something that you don't
know the hazards of yet
so a lot of people are generating
nanomaterials but how do we know that
they need to be contained well we don't
you know we don't really know until we
have that data so the best thing that
you can do is offer yourself some
protection and so I like to think of my
friend Al Pacino here and if he was you
know sitting in real life handling
hazardous drugs with a giant you know
amount of them sitting on a table in
front of them obviously that's you know
that's a risk that he's undertaking that
could cause severe health impact if you
were to sit in front of a pile of
nanomaterials its potential for health
implications can be equal to or even
more severe so obviously Al Pacino needs
a hood another way to help conceptualize
the hazardous nature of particles
whether they're drug particles or
nanomaterials is to look at how potent
these items can be to create a toxic
effect so here's a little example that
hopefully will help you understand how
even a small amount of nanomaterials can
be hazardous so here we're looking at a
the Empire State Building and then
you've got a 1 gram sweet sweet and low
sweetener packet so if we quantify these
so the Empire State Building is roughly
about a million cubic meters in that
package you've got about one gram only a
gram of of that on that sweetener or
sugar if you remove imagine yourself
standing on top of this building and you
open that package up and disperse that
tiny little gram into the entire volume
of that building you'd end up with a
concentration of sugar and a rating of
about one microgram per cubic meter so
if you step back away from this example
just for imagine for a second trying to
see one microgram per cubic meter in in
the air column in front of you in fact
you can't see it with the naked eye you
have to use a microscope the the naked
eye the human eye can really only see to
about a hundred micrograms per cubic
meter and that's what's really good
resolution
contrast so that would be a setting with
a white powder against a black
background and ample lighting so in
reality you know in your working
environments most people don't have you
know a suitable white substance with a
black background so it's even harder to
see that but that's okay for this
example we're only looking at the
microgram per cubic meter so you
certainly can't see it so all right if
we look at the the occupational exposure
limit for carbon nanotubes this is going
to vary depending on some you know some
characteristics of the nanotubes but
it's fall somewhere between 100 to 50
I'm sorry 1 to 50 micrograms per cubic
meter so at a concentration of even
higher than that little sugar packet
you're in a situation where you may be
experiencing unwanted health effects and
that's just operational exposure limit
sometimes you may be exposed to levels
that are much higher and you're not
still not going to be able to see them
with a naked high so there are ways to
contain particles and the best first
thing to do is to remove those particles
from the air or your breathing so we
take a fan and we turn it on we get two
things out of this so we get a negative
pressure area behind the fan blade and
then a positive pressure area on the
front and what this exhibits is
basically a push-pull effect so here
you've got air behind being pulled
towards that fan blade and once it's the
family that's going to be pushed or
positively pressurized away from that
source so the working force here is the
fan blade and you can imagine if you can
pull items towards the fan blade you're
controlling them but once they get on
the fan blades front side they're pushed
out and they kind of go wherever they
please so we like to keep everything
under negative pressure when we're going
to contain items because we can draw
that air towards a source well we know
in a laboratory setting that's that's
great to have a fan but you don't want
to just blowing everything around
everywhere so we can make that fan up
with a box and we for the terms of this
presentation we'll call this box a hood
or an enclosure sometimes you see that
words interchanged in this sense we'll
just approach it from a containment
device so in the side you're looking at
a side view you've got an opening on the
Left where all the air is coming in
that's the opening underneath the glass
sash and you'll notice that the air is
entering and kind of curving through
some air foils at the opening and then
also at the very top so all that air is
going to come in and then this is all in
the negative pressure side of the hood
the fan is going to be somewhere farther
upstream or I'm sorry downstream so air
is going to flow into this hood under
negative pressure and this is the
environment that you would want to work
with nanomaterials in because they're
going to be pulled away to the back of
the hood from you and then contained so
all right well if we push or if we pull
that containment towards the fan
eventually that fans going to have to be
located somewhere where anything going
on the other side of the fan is going to
be possibly pressurized and then we've
lost containment control so we can add
another feature into there that's a
filter so either a Hepper open filter
can be used for nanomaterials and these
are particulate filters so HEPA is
high-efficiency particulate air and Alba
is just simply a more dense version of
the HEPA filter and both of them are
made of borosilicate glass fibers that
are woven into a random weave and then
fold it into a filter that looks
something like what you're seeing on the
screen right now so here's you've got an
aluminum frame that has a gasket on it
and then although the filter media to
trap all of those particles before they
end up somewhere else in the lab or
ductwork of your building so one thing
that is important to note that when
you're looking at these filters is the
rating on them so they all have
different types of ratings of a filter
efficiency and what that means is it's a
rating basically of the weakest point at
which that filter can operate so in this
case we'd like to call that the most
the trading particle size and the
particle size actually changes depending
on the filter density so with a HEPA
filter that's rated for a 99.99%
efficiency that's actually its
efficiency with particles that are point
three microns size although filters are
more efficient and that's actually
measured at 0.12 microns and size so
those are the particles that actually
are most effective at getting through a
filter bed media so if you have a filter
or if you have a particle size that's
larger or smaller than the MPPs value
it's actually going to be trapped more
efficiently within the filter the way
that's done is through a couple of
different methods that particles
interact with a filter media so you've
got inertia interception diffusion and
electrostatic attraction and you can
kind of see how particles behave as
they're running into these filter media
so a lot of it is done through
interception and diffusion if you have a
lighter particle than the MPPs point so
really really tiny it's going to likely
diffuse because it's so light it's kind
of flying all around in the filter media
and will impact a fiber
as far as we'll get larger they're more
likely to experience interception and an
Internet inertial impact with
electrostatic attraction being pretty
rare given the fact that the media the
filter media is borosilicate glass which
often times doesn't return retain a very
strong charge
okay so now you've got a fan you've got
a box you've got a filter but that
filter is going to contain all of those
nanomaterials and other things in
laboratory that will be collected over
the life of the filter so you don't the
last thing you want to do is just pull
that filter right out into the
laboratory so a really important thing
to do is is operate under a barrier
system between yourself and that filter
the way you can do that is using a bag
in bag out or the Ibo
filter system so here you're seeing
technicians were tasked with changing
out a filter from a nano containment
hood and this is basically a system that
is more or less a glorified bag that
surrounds the filter crate and provides
a physical barrier between yourself and
the hazardous contaminants on the hood
this system actually really only exists
on hoods that had particulates in in use
inside the hoods and that's because
particulates so whether they're chemical
powders or nanomaterials or other
physical items they typically have a
very difficult time being decontaminated
or done or be made being made less
hazardous conversely if you work in a
biological setting and you have bacteria
or viruses those are items that can
typically be killed
and once sterilized with something like
vapors hydrogen peroxide they lose their
their their their dangerous
characteristics not all but some can be
killed that way so but when handling
nanomaterials here you are with a
physical barrier to keep those dangerous
materials intact in the filter and away
from yourself
so at this point a lot of people
typically ask me why not using why not
use a fume hood well think for a second
about what happens when you turn on a
fume hood fume hoods controlled by a
blower on the rooftop somewhere in your
building and anything that goes through
the hood is going to be run through that
entire length of ductwork and then pull
into the motor pull over and then
exhaust it through the outside into the
air column above the building normally
with chemical fumes chemical vapors
those items are ejected into the
airstream and diluted very rapidly they
don't have a physical mass they're just
a chemical vapor that dissipates over
time but with nanomaterials or powders
those are physical items that don't have
a way of being dispersed easily so they
end up in bad places they end up in the
ductwork they end up in the parking lot
and up in the blower and on the rooftop
all the areas that are where air passes
out of the hood and eventually onto our
places where there could be
contamination well that's not a great
use for a fume hood because there's
really no way to stop the nanomaterials
at any point and contain them so there
are a couple of options and here are two
commonly employed pieces of equipment
for nano material handling on the left
you'll see is a there's a nano
containment hood this is a hood that has
an opening and allows for easy organ on
ik work within the the area that's
containing there's a filter inside and
you'll see it generally represents what
you might know as a fume hood or
sometimes a balance enclosure or powder
containment hood the other hood as other
equipment on this slide is a glove box
glove boxes come in a lot of different
configurations but for nanomaterials the
key feature that you would want to see
is a box that has a bag in bag out
filtration either HEPA filters or Hopa
filters that help to keep everything in
the box in the box and prevent it from
getting into the room
so let's dive a little bit into the nano
containment hood so first off you've got
a negative pressure environment that's a
controlled airflow area that we know it
can help contain and trap those
hazardous particles that you may be
generating during a procedure so in this
cross section you'll see airflow flowing
to the back of the hood and it's
actually driven by a blower that's that
kind of whitish feature in the upper
part of the hood and then onward into a
filter
so good things about nano containment
hoods our construction of stainless
steel and this lowers the static charge
on the surfaces over definitely you
would not want to use something that's
made of plastic and also you want
something that's going to be easily
cleanable so stainless steel is not
particularly porous and it also stands
up to lots of cleaning materials I can
help get nano containment materials out
of crevices
I mentioned there's a filter so ulpa
filters can be the most effective at
nanomaterials and you would certainly
want to include a bagging bag out
containment feature for that filter
another important thing about a hood is
to have air foils and a baffle so in the
back you'll see that perforated wall
that's actually what it is is a false
wall and it helps to maintain air flow
distribution through the back of the
hood without having to race and speed up
the velocity of the air to any one
opening at the back you'll also notice
there are air foils and a baffle at the
front or I'm sorry just air foils at the
front those are on the top and bottom of
the opening so one serves as an armrest
and then also on the sides those help to
smooth out air as it enters the hood to
prevent any kind of turbulence that
might induce some escape of particles
back towards the users working area or
their sitting or standing
one other thing that can be nice for a
nano containment to help with static is
to integrate an ionizer so if you can
purchase a device that has an integrated
ionizer you can reduce the static and
the strange behaviors that some
nanomaterials exhibit the bum's act like
gases due to static and with an ionizer
you can at least help reduce some of
that static nature and help the hood
contain at a higher level another
consideration you should can take into
account is placement of that hood so
this is good practice for any type of
hood whether it's a fume hood a
biosafety cabinet or a nano containment
hood but you really want to locate this
like an open hood away from any kind of
source that's generating airflow so
heavy foot traffic areas doors that open
and close during working hours or even
the supply diffusers in the ceiling for
air return might feel good in the summer
but it also made ruin the containment
characteristics of a hood also if you
have a very sensitive balance that's
helping way nanomaterials you should
definitely want to stay close to a
load-bearing wall and if you can be
located on a lower floor or use items
such as a marble table or
dense materials I can help eliminate
building vibration in some instances
nano hoods are also vented and this
would be in conjunction with an
application that it uses hazardous
chemicals or perhaps as an added layer
of safety so let's say you have a nano
material that's going to be diluted into
a chemical obviously you would want to
contain that chemical vapor as well but
a HEPA filter or OPA filter inside a
hood is only going to stop the the
particulate matter that you're
generating any gas vapors or air will go
right through that filter so you need to
exhaust that to the outside or perhaps
investigated carbon filter as well
so let's talk about glove boxes for a
brief moment so obviously the number one
thing you'll notice about a glove box is
that it's a completely isolated
containment chamber so your access into
that opening is through a pastor on the
right or left side sometimes and once
you've got that material into the box
it's effectively sealed and leaked tight
so then your operation is carried out
through the globe ports on the front and
it can be a little bit cumbersome to
work into so it's really reserved for
opportunities in your laboratory or
working environment where you have
so-called high energy procedures which
are energies where you're moving or
mixing or or generating a lot more
aerosols and you might just typically be
carrying out in a smaller open hood this
extra barrier of being completely sealed
simply just ensures that even if you
were to spill something or create an
unwanted level of nanomaterials that
they're going to remain inside that
glovebox no matter what happens
also sometimes can be easy to get in and
out of say you have a laboratory
procedure where you need to get in and
out of the box several times to go
maintain another experiment or you know
do something else in the laboratory with
a glovebox you can simply leave the
gloves employ your hands out of the
gloves and continuing operations
somewhere else so getting into
characteristics of glove boxes you'll
notice a lot of similarities so ulpa
filters again with bag and bag out
capability allows you to remove those
filters when contaminated but in a safe
manner also stainless steels are really
important for cleanability ensuring also
that you can get into the corners and
crevices of these hoods to clean them is
a great way to ensure that you don't
leave any nanomaterials behind which can
reduce contamination with another
experiment and also is just a good
practice for cleaning the hood you can
integrate ionizing fans into these types
of boxes as well there are a lot of
options out there certainly investigate
when you're buying the box if you can
integrate one into that but you may also
find that you are using a balance that
came
than ionizer another thing is and this
applies for both this hood and also the
the nano containment hoods that are open
is that globe boxes and hoods for
nanomaterials testing should be tested
to a standard looking specifically at
nano particulate containment and I'm
going to talk a little bit now about a
company called nano safe and some of the
methods that they're employing to help
assess containment abilities for these
types of engineering controls like hoods
envelope boxes so some questions arose
as we started considering building these
types of hoods and and so we look to an
expert and the the foremost expert in
nano containment hoods right now is nano
safe
it's run by a gentleman named Matt hull
out of Virginia and some of the
questions you know we looked at from a
design component of these phases are
there any methods that exist right now
they're good for assessing nano
containment that's the most important
one obviously next one is if there are
ways to do it can you generate a nano
arrow cell to replicate real-life
experiments as as closely as possible
and then of course always assessing
limitations for that experimentation so
the first thing to look at is well
what's the what's available right now
and there are a lot of different ways to
assess the containment of a hood when it
comes to a chemical fume hood first
thing you can do is look to ASHRAE 110
which outlines a way to look at a gas
produced in the hood and the hoods
ability to contain so you'll see a lot
of things on the slide there's a tracer
gas detector located on a mannequin
there's an ejector for the gas that's
the thing on the left kind of left front
of the hood and then of course you have
all of this within the hood and this is
all really excellent for assessing vapor
containment of the hood it uses the
after a110 method uses the gas called
sulfur hexafluoride but that's a gas and
not a nano material so there is another
way to look at nano particulates
our excusing pharmaceutical powders
using air sampling devices to measure
for particulate escape but those
represents methods that are compatible
with chemical identification which is
not always easy to do with nanomaterials
so using a combination of both those
concepts we actually can assess nano
containment using some modified
components so obviously the first thing
you need to do is change the gas out for
a nano material you have to have a
generator that's compatible with the
Nano material and also you want to have
an environment that doesn't contribute
any background noise to the environment
so with a spray 110 sulfur hexafluoride
is used because it's not available
within the environment so it's not
naturally producing and can't be a
background contaminant what we need to
do a close as we can to that concept
with nano but sometimes is very
difficult because there aren't a great
breadth of non hazardous nanomaterials
that exist so we'll get into this in
just a brief second but first let's talk
about containment so so assessing the
the ability for the hood to contain has
to be done using a device that measures
so instead of using a gas sensor we
actually have to use nanoparticles size
measurement device and so here's one of
the most devices that was used by nano
safe and is still used obviously with
the changes in nano safe nanomaterials
constantly going on there are other
other options out there this is a
schematic of the operating method for
the device looking at protocol size and
I'll actually leave this to if you want
to ask questions about this I'll provide
the contact information at the end of
this webinar format hole and also for
nano scan but a little bit different
than ASHRAE 110 gas detection method
I also mentioned the troubles with
eliminating background noise so in this
test we used a silicon dioxide and
that's easy to generate it's relatively
safe but it sometimes is available in
the environment so to test a hood you
need to eliminate that background noise
and to do that is easily done in the
cleanroom
clean rooms are obviously not going to
be accessible in every environment or a
laboratory nanomaterial hood or glovebox
fizzes in place but certainly for the
sake of testing an initial basis these
are important characteristics to take
into consideration
right so now that we've outlined some of
the unique parameters let's talk about
the test material
so here's silicon dioxide and one of the
most important things to do is is hone
in on the particle size generated in the
environment because our detection system
is really looking for particle size not
for the chemical properties within that
silicon dioxide so here's a sample setup
of a hood undergoing a nano safe test
and you'll see here on this graph that
there's a mean particle size of the
silicon dioxide that was pretty stable
throughout test methods carried out with
this particular HUD so concentration is
important and as you see very stable
numbers on the particle diameter so we
know that whatever the particle counter
is looking at is truly what we're hoping
are what we're generating as a test
aerosol with the solid silicon dioxide
so in the hood we want to see lots and
lots and lots of the hood of particles
because we're generating silicon dioxide
out of this ejector and in fact if you
look at the distribution of particles
you'll notice that coming out of that
aerosol generator you're going to get a
significant amount of particles so this
is number of particles per cubic
centimeter and you're in the range of
about a hundred thousand particles per
cubic meter in the upper rate area of
the hood lower area of the hoods
experiencing quite a bit less particles
and that's because simply just the
ejector position so you'll notice here
ejector is emitting out of the top of
that device and so we expect the numbers
of particles to be higher up high
so that's good to see but we want to
know how well this hood contains so we
can look at the number of particles per
cubic centimeter as well on the outside
of the hood and so here's some data
representative of what was measured
outside of the hood both in the
background noise and also the sash
opening right where you're breathing
obviously you want to make sure that
whatever you're doing is not coming out
of the hood where you're breathing and
so if you compare these numbers you'll
see the background noise is actually
nearly identical to what was measured in
the sash opening of this hood so we know
that we're containing and not
experiencing escape from the hood of
these nanomaterials so they're
effectively being captured on to the
elbow filter within the hood and not
being re-entered into the room so here's
just a summary of the data so you're
looking at a common aerosol diameter so
we know that what we're designer rating
is what's being measured and then just a
quick look at the particles being
generated inside the hood versus outside
so we can assess basically a worst-case
containment rating of about 99.99%
effectiveness using a hood containing
nanomaterials
as with any good experimentation it's
important to consider some of the
limitations so first one is that without
further biological data and health data
it's really difficult to assess the
toxicity and exposure level
acceptability for various nanomaterials
even with some very common drugs that
you might take over your lifetime some
of those drugs have a limited Lee known
exposure limit nanomaterials oftentimes
are very novel and because of that
there's not a lot of investigation into
the health implications so if you can
take steps to just simply Ave evacuate
those particles from breathing area
that's the best possible thing you can
do without knowing the toxicity of those
components another important thing to do
is it's hard to test for all
nanomaterials so we use silicon dioxide
because it's easy to generate and also
easy to measure nanomaterials sometimes
behave very uniquely as we discussed
they have different physical
characteristics that make them hard to
contain hard to analyze and so it can be
difficult to adapt this test to every
type of material material you may be
using kind of coverage that's already
hard to know how dangerous stuff is
without more data and also unlike the
drug industry nanomaterials typically
don't have the burden of health and
safety when they're generated so
obviously FDA in the United States
regulates the toxicity and information
that on how a drug operates but if
you're manufacturing a component for a
computer and there is a generation of a
nano particulate you may not have the
same burden of safety to a governmental
organization like you may have with a
drug submitted through the FDA and also
to that and there's not really a good
regulatory guidance on how to behave
with nanomaterials there are information
publications out there NIOSH has nano
materials handling guidelines but
certainly
could always be more information out
there so with that the best thing you
can look at is containing those two
those procedures as best as you can
until further information is made
available with that I'm going to open it
up to some questions I hope you all
enjoyed the presentation and certainly
ask that you ask any questions now
during this live period and if you have
other questions after we're done you can
also send them to us via email and we'll
answer them individually
thank you David for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is we're
currently using a fume hood for a
process that generates nanoparticle
particulate is there a way to make our
fume hood suitable for nanoparticle
containment
so that's a great question the you know
obviously every lab has a lot of stuff
in it already I don't think I've seen a
lab recently that has a lot of extra
space on hand so if your only option for
any kind of containment versus open bent
as a fume hood the first thing you want
to do is assess if you can make such a
modification and one one consideration
that you might be able to adapt is to
add a filter in the ductwork there are
some manufacturers out there who me who
provide in ductwork hepa and ulpa
filters and options but I would caution
against using this as a primary fix for
your fume hood because you have to also
consider that any distance between where
you're generating particulates and where
that filter is located is now going to
be a contaminated space so imagine for a
second that you're generating
particulates and the filter is located
somewhere a hundred feet into the duct
run anytime that filter is modified or
adjusted or cut or or changed in the
future it's got to be treated as if it's
contaminated with nanomaterials so it's
especially important to see if you can
contrack particulates on a filter as
close to the source where they're
generated as possible
now David our next question are these
containment measures specific two types
of nanoparticles or are they for all
types of nanoparticles
um so they are generally specific are
I'm sorry they're generally applicable
to all nano containment nano
particulates although you know there are
some that be a very uniquely some that
are also air sensitive so there are
alternate containment options there are
glove boxes that can be completely
flushed of all oxygen and moisture and
still contain so I I would say if you're
handling a relatively inert simplistic
nano material carbon nanotubes etc those
are good fits for her for hoods with
airflow but if you have something very
unique has additional dangers I'd say
it's best to talk with your safety staff
first and and then get in touch with
someone like ourselves to discuss
potentials for containment
do all nano hoods need to be externally
vented
um I would say generally most are not
actually but the driving force there is
really one if you have chemical vapors
or things that would not be trapped by
the hepa or ALPA filter that would be
items that are in addition to the nano
particulates that you're using that
would be case number one where you would
not where you might consider an exhaust
for a hood the other one is perhaps your
safety personnel on site want some
additional protection so let's say you
know you moved the hood or damaged the
HEPA filter and then certaintly
and had not had it retested yet if the
hood was used and then exhausted your
could potentially plays an induct HEPA
filtration or LP filtration to act as a
redundant filter
now are there any drawbacks to using an
opus using opus l turfs
of all the filters so they're they're
really similar to a HEPA filter they're
just more dense material and in doing
that you're basically you're providing
an additional level of protection but
they also require more airflow a force
to go through that filter so if you have
a very messy application with lots of
powder just be prepared to change that
filter more frequently another thing
about that is if you have nanomaterials
that are in a on the larger side of
things closer to the point three micron
range you might consider using a HEPA
filter as that the HEPA filter will
still provide protection for those
larger particles at a highly efficient
rate and may afford you some longer
filter life
now David our next our next question is
going to be has does have two parts so
how about the bio polymeric
nanoparticles and can they be trapped by
these containment methods
good question and actually if you don't
mind I'm going to retain that question
to be answered by Matt hull Matt wasn't
able to join us today but is a nano
containment expert and if that's okay
I'll just defer that question to him and
have him follow up via email
so let's continue on let's continue on
with our next one now is there a good
way to measure for nanoparticles in our
lab environment yeah so so you can get a
particle counter specific for nano
material size constituents I discussed
one option there are lots and lots of
manufacturers out there who may make
particle counters for the nano scale
items and I would say if you don't have
one in your laboratory right now and
you're doing a lot of nano work you
should contact some a safety person on
site and consider maybe doing an
assessment either with an outside party
on a case-by-case basis or perhaps just
purchasing one of those yourself for for
as much testing as you need to control
and carry out on-site they do they're
not exactly cheap though I will caution
that so it's an investment to consider
versus having a third party measure and
provide assessments for yourself
and it looks like that is all the time
that we have for today so thank you
David do you have any final comments for
our audience no I want to thank
everybody for joining us today and I
know there are a couple questions that
we'll need to answer from Matt hull I
seriously advise all you to to go and
check out the nano safe website he's
offering a very nice approach to
consider measuring and doing assessments
for nano containment and if you have
questions about procedures in your
laboratory or working environment right
now he would certainly be one of the
foremost experts to contact and discuss
those applications with thank you again
David for your time today Andrew
important research we would also like to
thank laberd's and our sponsor lab Khan
Co for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the on
demand periods will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information that
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through june of 2019 leverets will alert
you via email and it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye